-Our next guest is an
Emmy-winning actor you know from
"Veep" and
"Arrested Development."
He stars in "Hocus Pocus 2,"
which is streaming now
on Disney+, as well as
"The Mysterious
Benedict Society."
The second season premiers
October 26th on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-You think I'll be elated to
hear you continue to claim
you ended the emergency?
A global crisis you're
wholly responsible for creating?
-Drop this ridiculous facade and
offer the truth -- now.
-No, it's not a facade.
-Oh!
-I believe the instigator of
a moment of change
can come from
an unexpected direction.
-Please welcome back to the show
Tony Hale, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
I'm so happy to have you
here in person.
-It's so nice to see everybody.
Your Trump impression
is very good.
-Thank you, you know?
-Very good.
-It was almost worth it for him
to be president, it's so good.
I sometimes --
I mean person-- No.
-Okay.
-So, I want to talk about
"The Benedict Society,"
but also -- So, "Hocus Pocus" --
you're in the sequel.
-Yes.
-A long-time-coming sequel.
-Mm-hmm.
-This is a Halloween classic.
Are you someone who likes
a good Halloween-themed film?
-No.
-Okay.
I think --
I would say "Hocus Pocus"
is kind of a level I like.
-Okay. So that's about
as scary as you want to go.
-Yeah. But I genuinely need
someone to explain to me --
There is so much fear
in the world.
I experience so much fear.
Why would I want to sit in
a room with other people
and watch people be murdered?
-Yeah.
-It doesn't --
I genuinely don't get it.
I don't get why people pay money
to go through haunted houses.
I'm like -- If I'm home alone,
I'm thinking someone's
going to jump out at me.
-So that's your haunted house
is just being home alone.
-That's a Tuesday.
But I really -- I genuinely --
Here's the thing.
People can watch
those scary movies
and walk away and be like,
"Well, it was fun."
I'm like, "Someone's after me,
and I need to protect myself
and my family."
-So, I mean, at least those are,
you know,
by and large, fictional.
What do you think about, like,
true-crime
documentaries and stuff?
-Dude, come on.
I genuinely --
Like the Dahmer show?
-Yeah.
-No, I'm not going to
watch that.
It's so terrifying,
and that's --
Like, watch CNN
and be just as freaked out.
-Right.
-Like, why are we doing this?
I'll watch, like,
YouTube videos of, like,
puppies coming home
to their owners
and stuff like that, you know?
-Usually, it's the owners
coming home to puppies,
but you watch --
-I just watch puppies
come home to owners.
-I mean, I didn't even
know those existed.
And then do the owners,
like, freak out?
-Oh!
-Those are...
-Woof, woof!
-From serving overseas.
The dogs have served overseas.
-There's a lot of
YouTubes like that.
-So, this is -- First of all,
the clip of
"The Benedict Society."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Very cool. You play two parts.
You play twins --
one good, one evil.
You also played two parts
in the new "Hocus Pocus" film.
And I think that
speaks to you as an a actor that
multiple directors have said,
"You should do both."
-Yeah.
Well, it's in my contract.
-Oh, so you only will now work
if you get to do two parts.
-Yeah. Scorsese will call,
and I'll be like,
"Does he have a twin?"
-So, have you said "no"
to Scorsese?
-Many times over.
Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
All the parts that went to
DiCaprio were originally you,
but he was like, "There's --"
-I was like,
"He doesn't have a twin."
-I like that you won't play
two different parts.
They have to be a twin, too.
-No, twin.
-It's like, "I got to parts.
I can play two parts.
I can play this guy, that guy."
You're like --
-Nope, twin.
Identical twin.
-These -- You know, being a
show, a wonderful kid's show,
do kids recognize you
on the street now?
-For "Benedict Society"?
Yeah, with a beard, they do.
Without the beard, they don't.
There's sometimes, though --
It's really sweet.
Like, if somebody --
When I did Forky,
someone will come up
and be like,
"Oh, he was the voice of Forky."
And the kid's like,
"That's not Forky."
And, so, it's really --
Oh, yeah, there he is.
-We've got a picture of Forky.
And, so, it should be --
I mean, I don't blame kids
for not thinking
that's you, right?
-Yeah. That's along
the realms of dogs
coming home to their owners.
But it's really fun
because I can do --
Like, I'll send
a little voice memo to them,
and their parents will play it.
And they'll show a video.
They'll play the video
of them hearing it,
and that's really fun.
'Cause they think Forky is real.
'Cause he is.
-You don't give it up
in the voice memo.
You don't, as Forky,
explain that "I'm always --
I've never been
real this whole time."
-And guess what else
is not real. No, no, no.
-But, you know,
guess what is real.
Jeffrey Dahmer.
And you can...
-Thank you.
-That was real.
-By the way, thank you.
So, why are we -- Why is this,
like, the top-rated show?
That's upsetting.
-It is very upsetting.
-Come on.
-You've been in a lot of shows
that I feel like
are quoted all the time.
You show up TikTok all the time.
"Veep" and
"Arrested Development."
Which I think speaks to
both your performance
and how incredibly
tightly written
those shows were
that they sort of endure.
Is that --
Do people come up to you
and quote lines
back to you all the time?
-Yeah, and there's a lot of
jokes I miss.
A lot, like,
-So, that you were part of.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Like, there's this joke
in "Arrested"
where my hand
is eaten off by a seal.
I don't know
if you guys remember.
And there was a great scene
in there where, like,
the doctor comes up,
and they say, "How's Buster?"
'Cause my character is Buster.
And they said, "He's okay,
but he lost his left arm."
It's kind of funny.
But then I'm doing
this podcast once,
and they said, "No, no, no,
that's not the joke.
The joke is, he said,
'He's all right,'
meaning he only has
a right hand."
Guys, that was 15 years
after I shot the show
that I got that joke.
That's sad.
Oh, and, recently,
I went to this great restaurant
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
called Union Special.
And they gave me this T-shirt,
and it said,
"Waking and baking."
And I was like,
"Oh, you know, I love bread."
So, I had -- So, like,
I wore this shirt
for like two years.
I wore this shirt to drop my
daughter off to school.
I wore this shirt to church.
And I would say
probably like two months ago,
someone was like,
"Oh, you did a little..."
[ Clicks tongue ]
And I was like, "What?"
I had no idea
it was about the weed.
-By the way,
even if it was about baking,
it does seem pretty
underdressed for church.
-Not my church.
-Okay.
-You got the laid-back kind?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Well, this makes sense that
someone that would wear
a T-shirt to church --
you did get your start here
in New York City
in the fashion industry.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay.
I temped.
One of my first temp jobs
was at "Vogue."
-Okay. So, you were just a temp,
and you got assigned to
"Vogue" one day.
-Yeah. I was at this
temp agency and I was --
Because I was auditioning
for commercials,
and you couldn't do a set gig.
You have to do it day-to-day.
-Right. Of course.
-And so, every day,
they'd send me somewhere new,
and they sent me to "Vogue."
And it was just like --
I was just like --
I looked like a bad Gap ad
in the middle of all --
Just khakis and,
like, surrounded by --
I was like a stain
in the fashion world.
-Did you clock it
immediately when you --
Did you expect it to be
that jarring
or was it when you walked in
that you realized,
"Oh, I'm not dressed --"
-Oh, It was immediate.
But I love those jobs.
For those of you
who have temped, back then,
we didn't have the cellphones
and all that stuff.
And I would make just
long-distance phone calls
all day.
I would just sit at the desk,
and, you know,
there's Anna Wintour,
and I was just like, "Hey, Mom."
Like, I was just making
long-distance phone calls.
So Wintour paid for my
-Oh, that's really nice.
And then, but that
was the end of it, right?
You had no communication with
"Vogue" after that.
-Well, they've tried to
contact me many times.
-They wanted to put you
on the cover,
but you were like, "As a twin?"
-Yeah. No.
Cut to a foldout.
-That was a very weird
September issue
when it was you
and then you folded it out.
-The month that "Vogue"
just goes to crap.
-You mentioned that kids only
recognize you with a beard.
Is the beard now something
you only have for the part
or are you bearded
in regular life now?
-I like the beard.
-The beard's really good.
-It's, like, a natural
kind of fat contour.
-Uh-huh.
-I kind of like it.
-I'm curious, though.
I know you have a daughter.
Does she like the beard?
Because when my boys -- Even
when I grow it out a little bit,
they don't care for it at all.
-Yeah, I think -- Yeah.
Mine's 16 now, and she's --
She'll be 17 in February.
-Wow. What piece of your work
does she like -- None of it.
-None of it.
-Ever. At any point?
I mean, 'cause I guess,
like, Forky,
she's too old for Forky
when it happens, probably, or...
-Yeah, she was
too old for Forky,
but even when she was little,
we didn't watch
"Arrested Development."
I mean --
-Yeah, that's not
a great little --
By the way, I love that you're
like, "Dahmer's too rough,"
and then you told us,
"There's this really funny scene
where a seal eats my arm."
-Yeah, exactly.
And then the seal eats it.
But there is this one scene
on "Arrested" where --
just talk about a picture of
co-dependency --
where my mother,
played by Jessica Walter,
the late Jessica Walter,
who was wonderful.
She was on house arrest
and she couldn't smoke.
And Buster had to inhale
the smoke out of her mouth
and then blow it out
on the balcony
and then come back, inhale
the smoke out of her mouth,
like a baby bird.
And I'm like, "Do I want to
watch this with my daughter?"
-Probably a good decision.
I think let her find it
on her own.
Hopefully, one day,
she'll go off to college,
and people will say,
"Oh, my God.
Your dad was in
the funniest show."
-She's like, "No, he wasn't.
That's not my dad."
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Thanks for having me.
-Really appreciate it.
-So fun. So fun.
-Tony Hale, everybody.
"Hocus Pocus 2" is
streaming now on Disney+,
and the second season of
"The Mysterious
Benedict Society"
premieres on Disney+
October 26th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."